[Music]
yesterday in the age of 42 he passed
away Muhammad was I'd rather not be
remembered as an addict and an alcoholic
who put his family through hell yeah you
know what I don't know why but I'm quite
moved to be honest
[Music]
shows how sad these people are the
convicted racist politician who is
notorious for his so-called Crown
burning Taurus and then his car flipped
over here
just because it brings peace to your
soul and peace to your heart it is the
truth you're trying to build a Dallas
Center here Islam is violent by Nature
my friends if a Christian goes and kills
a bunch of Muslims you're going to blame
every Christian for it no no who are you
going to blame for it first Samuel 15 3.
he ended up putting the Quran to the
test
is
I became much more happy after I became
Muslims I would like to invite everybody
to become Muslim
[Applause]
alive
and his final message
be upon him this is our religion Islam
Islam this is the beach
and I was explaining how much respect I
have for the faith of Islam welcome to
the beach
is the author of the Divine reality God
Islam and the Mirage of atheism he's
also the founder of the sapiens
Institute
and something else you want to know
about him not only does he eat Greek
food he speaks Greek you guessed it he's
Greek and we want to find out why is he
talking so positively about Islam right
in all these books and here with us on
the dean show with my next guest
Hamza this is your brother Hamza Andreas
and I want every single one of you to
support Eddie from the dean show
financially and otherwise but in what
way
I want you to support his new project
the dean Center is going to be a
transformative experience in this Center
why because it's going to be a Masjid
it's going to be a place of worship it's
also going to have Fitness facilities
and it's also going to be a dollar
Center to call people back to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala Muslims and
non-muslims and we trust Eddie
completely I for one will take a
thousand bullets for Eddie he has a
vision he has more than 15 years of
experience in the dawah he's had a huge
success with the dean show and he has
the support of many Duart and preachers
and Scholars from all around the world
it's going to be an amazing project for
everybody go to the dean center.org
donate now
[Music]
foreign
and I forgot to mention I forgot to
mention in the introduction and my
brother who take a thousand bullets from
me I for one would take a
test absolutely a thousand and one
coming from your own words yeah you
really touched my heart with that
alhamdulillah no no absolutely because
you know the dawa is an interesting
space and it's kind of rare to have
individuals who have had longevity
who are able to bring people together
so you're like the glue that brings
people together Eddie and that's what I
love about it that's what everyone loves
about you and you know you don't get
involved in dramas you're fixated and
allah-centric I've had a Centric gold
which is just to please online just to
get Humanity to understand that they
should worship the Creator not the
creation you want to free Humanity from
the shackles of associationism the
shackles of shirk the shackles of bowing
down internally and externally to other
than Allah you wanna free them from that
so they could connect with our Rahman
the most merciful the most loving and
and that's what you've been doing and
that's why I'll take a thousand a
million bullets for you inshallah
you're bringing back so many memories
before we start talking about the Quran
burner before we start talking about
some of these other current things that
are going on that I want to get your
feedback from you bringing back a lot of
memories good memories I'm thinking
about about you I'm looking at you and
I'm thinking about Bosnia
yes uh we're together we're eating we're
having some lunch my father's there uh
uh how was your experience in Bosnia
it was a very good experience actually
it was a very positive experience I mean
obviously I love engaging with you as
always but the Duart that were there the
brothers that were there who wanted to
share Islam with hikmah with wisdom with
hasana with good preaching they were
there they wanted to be touched moved
and inspired so they can call Humanity
with that wise compassionate goodness
and I was
just given the opportunity by Allah to
engage with the Dua to learn from them
as well but also engage with them so we
could uplift each other
and as you know the Bosnian space the
social political space is not an easy
one it brings sad memories because we
all remember what happened
and I think it's very important for us
to engage in this type of work because
the beautiful thing about calling people
to Islam there's many layers to it of
course you want to make Allah's worth
the highest you want people to go to
Jannah you want people to be guided but
there are so many layers to the dower
and one aspect of this especially when
it comes to social political realities
is that you could bring people together
Allah says in the Quran that he created
us from a male and a female and he
basically created us into different
tribes and nations in order for us to
know one another
to know one another now what's
interesting here if you look at the
classical exegesis the classical
explanation of this verse many scholars
explained that this does not mean trying
to find out what makes you common it
means find out what makes you different
find out what makes you distinct and why
is that important think about it from a
social perspective
fear happens anxiety happens all of
these things happen because there are
differences but once you explain the
differences
you explain the differences you give it
a a Humanity if you like you give it
give the truth behind these differences
those differences no longer become
sources of fear or anxiety but they
become sources of getting to know one
another and coming together in different
tribes and Nations and groups hopefully
those people to become Muslim if they
don't at least it lessens the anxiety
and the fear so from a Bosnian context
we don't want that to ever happen again
in one way and there are many ways but
one way of trying to ensure it doesn't
happen again what happened in Bosnia in
the 1990s is actually to engage in dawa
because there's that sense of Lita arafu
that sense of getting to know one
another to remove those anxiety in those
fears yes hate is always going to hate
you're gonna have those ideal logs you
can have those nationalists you're gonna
have those people who who don't want
Muslims and Humanity to flourish but we
have to do our role and I think engaging
in dawa facilitates that childhood and
you reminded me uh you were talking
about the trees and then I went back and
researched that and you were dead on
there has been a lot of research on the
actual communication between trees yes
and then we had that's reminding me of
the conversation that we had yes you
reminded me do you remember that and you
pointed to a specific book and yes
that's that you were talking about the
communication between the tree then
reminded us of the Hadith where the
Prophet saws talked about because some
people get caught up on they say come on
how could trees speak and there's modern
day research on this and you actually
you were articulating that in our last
discussion there in Bosnia yeah there
was a book it's called if I remember
correctly the hidden life of trees and
trees actually communicate in their own
way with each other and they almost like
live in communities and there's a sense
of tree the algorithm like trees will
sacrifice themselves for other trees and
it's quite interesting because I always
ask people are you a beach person or are
you a forest person and me I'm more of a
forest person because it's alive you
know trees are communicating trees are
living in communities and they're
sharing and they're communicating and
for me you get a sense of that you know
so there is something in the tree
huggers you know what you have these
these hippies we hug trees obviously we
don't do it for you know key reasons but
there's a sense of energy when it comes
to trees right and we know the famous
Hadith of the Prophet saws or the
narration and the story of the tree
actually cried yeah so
that is not far-fetched especially look
at today's research and what's
interesting when a group of community or
trees are together and there's an animal
that basically
bites or takes the leaf of one of the
trees that tree was sent at like a gas
signal to the other trees and those
trees will make their leaves more bitter
so the animals would be repelled it's
very very fascinating so there's so much
in it in that
okay so getting from the blast from the
past you reminded me of really good
memories um I really really enjoyed uh
being with you and so did my father and
tell me this okay so as I opened up you
eat Greek food you speak Greek you're
Greek
and you know with the history of uh
Bosnia also and that area there Bosnia
is like the they say the the Jerusalem
of Europe and there's been some tensions
over the years so what you would think
someone from a Greek background your
story's out there people can go ahead
and look it up but just for the people
tuning in for the very first time and
they're saying Hamza resources and he's
writing books on Islam I mean these are
not anti-islam books are they
but there's a lot of Greeks not just
yourself so you're you're a Muslim Greek
yeah is that correct what did it for you
just real real briefly then we'll get
into the the other things we want to
talk about yeah I mean I became Muslim
around 20
years ago
and so 21 years ago 22 years ago and
alhamdulillah became Muslim for three
main reasons number one Islam made sense
to me
satisfied my mind number two I really
appreciate the Brotherhood in Islam that
sent us all of Brotherhood that
transcended Nation transcended blood if
you like very close Brotherhood and
number three I was attracted to many
Islamic values so those were the three
main reasons
beautiful so we got it made sense the
Brotherhood and the values and we often
say that if these people would go ahead
and pick up the Quran
and they would put it to truly sincerely
put it you know implement it into their
lives they wouldn't end up as a sad
reality that many people like these were
going to talk about and we want good for
them also we want we have love for
Humanity and we want them to go ahead
and experience uh what we're
experiencing so they don't end up like
these people taking their own lives so I
want to get into uh this this recent one
actually we'll start off from which I
talked about before because this seems
like a common Trend and I just someone
just shared with me this recent some
tick tocker before we get into him he
was also someone who was uh insulting
Prophet Muhammad in Islam there was this
this individual and then it's like a
pattern you could see their lives just
unfolding in front of us let's stop with
this and get your reaction and we'll go
one by one
depressed
and they don't want to live anymore and
in the end they take their own lives
it's Quran burner in the picture it's a
Quran burner that is living in Norway
yesterday in the age of 42 he passed
away this picture on the screen is from
the 26th of November when he was trying
to destroy our Tower stand in Oslo in
Norway they get depressed and they don't
want to live anymore and in the end they
take their own lives for some of the
chats between Swedish Danish politician
Rasmus polidan and young boys on the
internet the convicted racist politician
who is notorious for his so-called Crown
burning Taurus and anti-islam hate
spends extensive time on social media
platform Discord chatting with young
boys about sexually explicit topics
[Music]
although paludon has been charged with
14 offenses in the past including racism
defamation and traffic laws his online
chats did not elicit any action under
Danish law okay before we get into the
new current ones what do you think
what's unpackaged what's going through
your mind when you see we talked about
what Drew you to Islam the values right
this moral code what kind of moral code
do you think that people are living by
and what's driving them at the end to
take their own lives or to go down this
road of you know trying to pick up young
boys
yeah you know what I don't know why but
I'm quite moved to be honest
um
because it just shows a few things
number one the power of the Quran and it
shows it really shows how sad these
people are now there's a very beautiful
eye in the Quran in the 20th chapter in
the 124th verse Allah says
but whoever turns away from my reminder
will certainly have a miserable life
and then we will raise them up blind on
the day of judgment now
many people may know and if you don't
know let's explain this what does the
reminder mean according to the mufasarin
which means those classical Orthodox
Scholars that explain the Quran
also known as exegetes they do exoduses
they explain the Quran the reminder is
another name for the Quran
so this is so powerful
but whoever turns away from my reminder
meaning the Quran itself will certainly
have a miserable life then we will raise
them up blind on the day of judgment and
this is very fascinating because if you
think about this Surah itself right the
beginning of the Surah what does Allah
say in the second verse
he says we have not revealed the Quran
To You O Prophet to call you distress
in other words you can mirror the
meaning that Allah has revealed the
Quran to bring a sense of a sense of
happiness and but if you go all the way
down to 124 verse 124 Allah says Those
Who reject the reminder the Quran itself
they will have a miserable life
this is so powerful
and it goes to show those people who
hate the Quran basically is a form of
self-hatred let me explain something
I'll let this from a scholar once
you will find yourself in the Quran
brothers sisters friends Humanity you
will find yourself in the Quran in
reality you don't read the Quran the
Quran reads you
and you will find yourself in the Quran
and you have to really check your heart
to understand if you're approaching this
book with sincerity with with a yearning
for for the Creator or is it to find
something negative or to impose your own
ego and your own negativity because
many of these people that pointed the
finger at the Quran the three there are
three fingers pointing back this
politician he was caught doing things
with or expressing himself in an
inappropriate inappropriate
inappropriate way with young children
this other
I think Norwegian fellow who's burning
the Quran or Danish fellow he actually
uh committed suicide right he's pointing
the thing at the Quran that it's
destructive it's there's no guidance but
look at his life and this is very
interesting because in the third chapter
of the Quran in verse 7 Allah talks
about the ambiguous verses and the
unambiguous verses meaning the the
verses that have potentially multiple
interpretations of the open to
interpretation and the verses that are
very clear and Allah tells us gives us
advice to stick to those verses that are
very clear they're the mother of the
book the foundation of the book we
understand the whole Quran through these
verses and Allah warns us the more
ambiguous type of verses
people who have a sickness in the heart
are going to try and do some kind of
interpretation their sickness is going
to come out in a way so from that
perspective when people approach the
Quran and they're already sick they're
already full of hatred then they would
find themselves in the Quran they would
find themselves in the Quran they won't
find a valid interpretation but they
would find themselves because that's the
nature of the book of Allah it can guide
you or it could be a source of your
misguidance as well because you are the
one who has closed the door to guidance
you have pushed away the guidance and
you are rejecting The Message of Islam
in its clear form because they just like
Allah says in chapter 3 verse 7 that
they're trying to twist and do dodgy
interpretations of the ambiguous verses
right so from that perspective my kind
of theory is you would find yourself in
the Quran
and you see that in these people they
they point fingers at the Quran they say
the Quran is full of you know dark
things because they don't have a true
understanding and they don't interpret
the Quran the way the Quran tells them
to understand the Quran which is to say
it with Through The Eyes or through the
lenses of the clear
unambiguous verses and you see things
far more holistically and you see the
picture not just a pixel
and from that perspective I think uh
this just shows to us how powerful the
book of Allah is these people are
um sick people and they have found they
have imposed the sickness on the Quran
and it's balanced back on them as Allah
says in chapter 20 verse 1 to 4 that if
you reject this reminder you're going to
have a miserable life and look what
they're doing they're they're doing
inappropriate things or saying
inappropriate things with young children
and or the committing suicide or they're
having a depressed life then Allah says
they're going to be raised blind on the
day of judgment on the day of
resurrection and may Allah protect us
you know and you know what's interesting
as well Eddie the burning books I mean
isn't this what you know backward
medieval people used to do yeah burn
books right and then you know what the
irony is they're framing as if this is
freedom of speech yeah that's how
they're framing it freedom of speech but
and they're forgetting their own
tradition because the objectives of
freedom of speech as John Stuart Mill
said one of the famous British
philosophers
the main objective of freedom of speech
was human flourishing in other words we
want truth we want to account
hold power to account we want progress
scientific progress how does burning a
book facilitate truth how does burning a
book allow progress how does burning a
book you know give you civilizational
advancement this is not freedom of
speech this is
uncivilized Behavior
and this is what we need to tell people
you you you need to read the Quran not
burn the Quran so you could be elevated
you could be guided you could progress
as a civilization and it's the mark of a
defeated civilization that they actually
celebrate burning religious texts this
is let's just be honest it is the mark
it is the sign of a defeated
civilization if they celebrate and
protect the burning of books
and this goes against the main
objectives of freedom of speech anyway
which were about human flourishing it
was about progress scientific
advancement and burning books does not
facilitate that at all I like what you
said self-hatred are projecting of
what's in you have people with uh
with dark hearts and then they're
they're talking about there's darkness
in in the Quran but then you see this
darkness in their hearts and they're
trying to end up projecting it out
worldly from what's within let's go on
here I know you also you're pretty um
into uh boxing
and recently again we don't condone any
violence or
uh harming anybody but this was uh
something that was that came up with a
another Quran burner I wanted to get
your uh feedback um because you'd like
to throw a nice jab and hook cross so I
don't know if you've um have any
comments on this
look at all
[Music]
seems like this is another Quran burner
that that popped up and then somebody
put on some boxing gloves and uh
challenged him I guess to uh to a
one-on-one fight uh what were your
thoughts on that
well well I I don't know what to say I
mean I just came from the back from the
gym about an hour or so ago I did about
seven rounds on the on the back it's
quite interesting you mentioned that so
I mean I don't know the context that
person was a Quran burner the other
person seems to be a Muslim and he wants
to take some kind of Revenge or he wants
to basically hold him to account but one
thing is it's quite interesting that the
guy who's been in the Quran you know he
can't he doesn't look like he could
fight at all secondly he tried to pick
up a weapon like a coward
um that's one thing I wanted to mention
the second thing is look in our context
we have to understand dawa so Allah says
in the Quran in chapter 16 verse 1 24
125.
call to the sabil the way of your lord
how
with wisdom and preach in what in the
best way with goodness now this is very
important
Allah doesn't say call to the way of
your Lord with the AIM
with knowledge he says with hikmah
because what is hikmah Yes means the
Sunnah but broadly it also means from an
Islamic perspective that you have a goal
that is pleasing to Allah and you apply
your aim your knowledge in a particular
context to achieve that goal this is
very deep I want everyone to listen to
this
is you have a goal that is pleasing to
Allah and you apply your in your
knowledge
and you apply in a particular context to
achieve that goal and hasana goodness
also includes eh San Excellence
sincerity includes being merciful and it
includes doing the right thing in the
right way which sometimes means you have
to be assertive now in our context of
the Quran burning we have to understand
what our goal is as a community in
Europe what the context is and how we
apply item in that context and I would
say
this type of person instead of us
showing any type of aggression because
that's what they want from us they want
us to be aggressive they want us to show
violence they want to provoke us but we
have to have a sense of elevated
standard in this context
is one of the characteristics of the
Prophet Muhammad
and Helen means forbearance being
patient with aggression being patient
with negativity being patient with
hatred because Allah says in the Quran
in Surah chapter 41 verse 33 and 34.
Allah says in verse 33
call to the way of your lord
call the who is sorry who is best in
speech than the one who
calls to the way of the Lord the one who
called to tahit the one who calls to the
Oneness of Allah does righteousness
and says I am one of those who submit
that's verse 33 verse 34 beautiful verse
this is the Verso of Helm of forbearance
good and evil are not the same
good and evil are not the same repel by
that which is better
and between two people if there's any
hatred it will turn to intimate
friendship
and this is difficult except for the
patient interestingly in the Arabic here
Allah doesn't use the Arabic word repel
and he does so he uses the word Arabic
repel and it's not followed by a direct
object Allah doesn't say repel evil it's
open-ended repel by that which is better
and the ulama the scholars they say
repelling by that which which is better
means repelling by what is more
beautiful and what is more virtuous in
this context in our ideological context
and the context of Europe in the context
that they want us to look like the evil
Batman or the aggressive man we need to
now have Helm forbearance
and we need to repel by that which is
more beautiful and by that which is more
virtuous
in this context and between two people
there's any hatred it will turn to
intimate friendship and this is what we
need to do in that particular context so
I don't condone Brothers going out there
putting boxing gloves on and basically
you know trying to attack this guy what
we should do is show a sense of hidden
just like the prophet saws if you
remember the famous Hadith the prophetic
tradition when the Jewish man came to
Prophet Islam he pulled him by the color
or the neck
and he demanded for repayment of a loan
and one sahabi companion was acting a
bit assertively aggressively and the way
the prophet salallahu reacted was with
him and forbearance he gave advice to
the companion to basically calm down and
he told and he told him you should
basically advise this man to ask for his
repayment the repayment of a loan in a
better way
and upon seeing this the Jewish Man
became Muslim because he was looking for
the three signs of prophethood he saw
two of the signs and the final sign was
forbearance Helm meaning that we forbear
we repel
aggression we repel hatred with what is
more virtuous and what is more better
and what is more beautiful and that's
how we should be in the context of dawa
yes okay fine I do understand where the
brother's coming from he's probably
frustrated he's angry but remember what
does Allah say this is very difficult
except for the patient though so we
should in inco cultivate that patience
have taqwa have good Consciousness hold
on to the Quran hold on to the Sunnah
and deal with these people in the most
allocentric way meaning what is the goal
that we're trying to achieve remember
Dao is about ekma and Allah pleasing
gold and allah-centric goal we apply our
knowledge in the particular context that
we're engaging with in a European
context with islamophobia with the
liberal hegemony with the ideological
forces against the Muslims us being
minorities on all of these things it's
time for us to hold on sort of hold on
to sort of chapter 41 verses 33 and 34
call to Allah with righteousness say
we're one of the most systems are one of
those who submit and will repel anything
by that which is better and between two
people with any hatred will turn to
intimate friendship and that's what we
should be focused on in our particular
context all right moving along so before
we get into this one I also had the the
person who had his car flipped over he
got into a Chase right I don't know if
you saw that one that clip where the one
who was coming to the to the brothers
there in Norway and then so the women
they came up next to him and they
started chasing him and then his car
flipped over there
you remember that one just like why what
are you trying to accomplish at the end
I like what you said what brought you to
Islam it made sense the Brotherhood the
values there's there's a gift that the
Creator is giving you you have this book
instead of burning it open it read it
sit with the Muslims
is going
and the next one in line
is there is no God Muhammad was a
warlord he did not speak to God he was a
bad man I'd rather not be remembered as
an addict and an alcoholic who put his
family through hell but unfortunately
that's also part of me an atheist tick
tocker by the name of Von vindi whose
real name is Joe
died after committing suicide The Tick
tocker who insulted the Mohammed peace
and blessings be upon him he released a
short video saying he was an addict and
an alcoholic who put his family through
hell before taking his own life our
condolence to the family
so what can we say you see a consistency
a trend here the people who end up going
down this path
are people who end up usually like in
these cases taking their own lives
they're unhappy
they're involved in many things that are
just destroying them from within and
then they end up projecting that and
then they do a lot of these wicked and
evil things like
insulting over two billion people why
would you do that
if you're unhappy
with yourself and you're not able to
figure out the purpose of life why
you're being creative while you're here
you're miserable a happy person is
projecting these good the good energy
but this unhappy person who's miserable
for within he's not trying to change the
world for the better himself you see
what he's doing make a mockery of
himself
and while he's insulting
two over two billion people like we said
so comes Resources with us we have some
you know technical difficulty here it
was great having you on the program my
brother
inshallah we're gonna have to continue
again we lost you there
due to this technical
difficulties that we're having so let's
go ahead and conclude everybody there's
one person that I want you guys to think
of
there's been a couple actually one that
comes to mind is uh joram van
foreign
[Music]
he was also somebody who was a staunch
opponent to the Quran to Muslims he was
a politician
and he was vigorously
going and doing things like like these
people were doing and he ended up
putting the Quran to the test so instead
of burning the Quran he read the Quran
and he found what hamza's horses found I
became much more happy after I became
Muslims I would like to invite everybody
to become Muslim just because it brings
peace to your soul and peace to your
heart it is the truth it resonates with
heart and soul at least look at it from
an Islamic perspective try to read and
study the life of the Prophet try to
understand what the Muslims believe not
so much the behavior of Muslims because
there are a lot of Muslims that don't
live like Muslims including myself I
don't always live like a Muslim and
shoot so what can we conclude from this
don't burn the Quran read the Quran come
and connect with the Muslims visit your
local mosque ask your questions engage
and if you go to the deaneshow.com we
will send you a copy for free that's
right my gift to you the Quran and if
you have questions call
tell them I sent you tell him Eddie sent
me and I because naturally if you've
been exposed to much of the fake news
the false information to lies have
truths it might affect you we totally
understand and get that so it's your
right to ask questions be sincere and
about it though be sincere call
1-800-662 Islam 662-4752 and ask I heard
this this and the other please can you
explain that you might be scared
thinking Islam and Muslims are the
boogeyman coming to get you it's
laughable to us but to you we can
understand when you've been fed the
wrong information
and now it is manufactured fear they are
perpetuating this stuff and you're
naturally you're ignorant you don't know
that's what ignorance is you just don't
know but it's your choice do you want to
get informed you want to stay in the
Bliss of ignorance or do you want to be
enlightened do you want to get to know
do you want to go ahead and keep adding
one plus one is seven one plus one is
five or do you want someone to teach you
another correct addition to that is one
plus one is two you know the light ball
goes on you feel better you'll feel much
better about yourself I'm telling you so
visit the Muslims love they love when
people come visit Damas and engage with
us recently had an experience and I saw
a
a Christian outside and I was like man
it's a great opportunity to talk to him
but this guy is screaming at the top of
his lungs we're coming out of what's
called Juma and this guy's not engaging
he's there preaching and he's there
shouting and he's not sitting there and
talking with us asking questions
uh he's coming along like he knows but
he doesn't know and what what's
happening he's chasing people away and
this is where religion in general and we
would ask the Christian Community for
people like this for coming out of juman
a person like this
screaming and yelling how you doing my
friend
pillars how are you doing I'm not
talking to you right now you're a solo
you're trying to build a dawa Center
here Islam is violent by Nature my
friends we've been told that uh they're
out to kill us all right brothers and
sisters we went to the streets to ask
Americans about Islam here's what they
said do you know anything about Islam No
do you know anything about Islam No
sadly do you know anything about Islam
uh not really do you know anything about
Islam
no I'm sorry you know what Islam means
Islam uh no we've been told that uh
they're out to kill us all that's what
you've been told that Muslims are out to
kill you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you're gonna have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many Americans who don't
know about Islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click to donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
that just like we we hold to account if
somebody's stepping out of line having
some extreme radical Behavior we the
community we will talk to this person we
will engage with them we will try to
help them Rectify their ways and tell
them they don't represent us we've done
this so many times on the program
condemning that Fringe element and this
I'm sure this is in your community a
fringe element that tomorrow can do
something very violent and extreme
because what person altogether you're
standing in front of a house so imagine
the Muslims are doing that standing in
front of a church a synagogue and
screaming and yelling the news will be
all over this at least thinking that
this is like what Islam preaches and
teaches and whatnot so if this guy wants
to engage with the Muslims or anybody
else we are actually very elated when
you come we'll come and we'll invite you
in and go ahead and ask any question as
long as you're sincere you're genuine
you're not trying to go ahead and you
know be a smart alec and you know look
for trouble I mean
where are you gonna go with that so when
a person is really trying to connect
make the human connection we have so
many things in common let's get the
elephant out of the room obviously we
don't believe that Jesus is a he's not a
god A literacy of God okay we can agree
to disagree you guys believe he's got
Trinity Etc we believe that God Almighty
is one and alone worthy of worship that
nothing should be a worship alongside
with God that Jesus called people to
worship the Creator in Aramaic Allah
that's how you say in Aramaic you say
Allah that's how you call on God that's
the language he spoke sister language to
that is the Arabic language and there's
a whole chapter named after his blessed
mother called Miriam so you'll see that
we do not say any disrespectful thing
about Jesus okay so we get this out of
the way we get this out of the way that
we can agree to disagree just like you
might have in your own family someone
who you disagree with so we disagree
upon this but what about all the things
that we agree on that the sexualization
of children at this young age it should
not be happening we could stand together
in self-death to this we can go and work
on many of these other things that we
agree with like the family structure
that there is a way that God created
it's through marriage and there's a male
and a female and all these other
hundreds of genders no this is not found
in the Bible in the Quran or any
religion so this is something that we
can work together to protect our
communities our families from what's
Happening Now you can see this but and
we're coming if we're having people like
this guy hey everybody I've talked to
this guy if you make Jesus Lord and
believe the gospel my friends you can be
saved we have really invite people to
come to them
go ahead and by his grace have some
water have some tea but you got this guy
screaming with you let's try again a God
he wants to have a relationship with you
how are you doing a guy who wants to
have a relationship with you what's your
name you guys the Bible says the Bible
says Surah 9 was written last okay about
what you want to promote violence I know
who you are I'm filled with the Holy
Spirit you need to repent
promoting a violent a violence
in our in our country if a Christian
goes and kills a bunch of Muslims you
gonna bring every Christian for it
who are you going to blame for it yeah
so if a Muslim doesn't act of terrorism
why are you blaming the religion for it
show me in scripture I'll show you from
your scripture first Samuel 15 3. and
they were going against God's word
killing innocent children this is in
your Bible in front of you so this is
not the word of God then because it's
got the words of humans that are wrong
well yeah so who made the Quran a human
no no the Quran is revealed by Allah
with perfection not a single mistake in
it have you ever read the Quran
I'm gonna give you a Quran just read it
and give me give me this thing you can't
be out here
promoting hate against Islam and stuff
bro you're right that's not happening
all right you're gonna read the Quran
come in and screaming and insulting and
whatnot this is not going to work we we
wouldn't do it to you guys we shouldn't
be doing it you shouldn't be doing it to
us and if the community Christian
Community can hold their own
to account like this and say hold on
there's a better way and then people
they look at this say these these
religious people they're just nut jobs
all together it just makes everybody
look bad
anyway so with that said I
want to thank again my guest
and we're gonna have to do it again
Hamza sorry lost you there and for
everybody else continue to tune in here
to the dean show
and don't forget to pick up that free
copy of the Quran at the deanshow.com
website and call us if you have any
questions subscribe so you don't miss
any of the up and coming programs that
we have for you and we'll see you next
time inshallah until that peace be with
you
if you like this episode of the dean
show go ahead and click this video up
here or up here for more and don't
forget to like all the videos so more
people can go ahead and benefit just
like you have hit that notification Bell
subscribe we'll see we'll see you next
time until then peace be with you